Jesse Williams calls out petitioners who  want him fired from Grey's Anatomy for  his controversial BET's speech if you  have no interest if you have no interest  in equal rights for black people then do  not make suggestions to those who do sit  down  on Wednesday the actor broke his silence  on the change.org petition writing quote  not a single same sentence in their  claim not one the petition has garnered  more than 19 thousand signatures the  gray star continued his Twitter rant  possibly referencing the death of Alton  sterling who was reportedly shot by  police in Louisiana  woody Noble Patriots please provide a  list of infractions punishable by  spontaneous public execution quote upon  receipt of this list we'll return to our  quarters and study up he finished with  you chumps we'll never provide this list  we see through you Gray's creator Shonda  Rhimes also responded to the petition  with this cheeky tweet quote boo don't  need a petition